Alright guys, so here is example two. You can clearly see that we had a bearish candle on the daily
And we just slightly closed below it as you can see by here
So now our red draw on liquidity is going to be this daily low around here. So now if I go to the five minute time frame
Right, this is
Currently the load that I have marked out
So now we're gonna wait for the Asian session to start over
Remember this is our draw on liquidity, right? So now we're gonna be taking shot position with the air 50 model
So just around here, which you can see at two we have the Asian session low and
The Asian session high over here and we close to blow it. So now we're gonna take our Fibonacci tool
you're gonna use from the high to the low of the Asian range and
And that's gonna be this level
It's a 0.5 level that is from where we're gonna take our entry put our shop right above the
Asia high and
Our draw on liquidity is gonna be this low here. So let's move this and let's see how this plays out
So we get our entry
Remember this is our draw on liquidity and look at that beautiful movie downside giving us 4.75 restore what ratio
So this is basically how I trade the the air 50 with bias
Of course, I use the external and internal liquidity method as well
But this method I think you should be using this because it is easy and it should not complicate things
This is gonna be it. Thank you so much guys for watching the entire course
This is gonna be it for the course updates in the future
I'm gonna release something else but for now this is gonna be it and I'm not gonna upload anything else in this course specifically
Because I do not want to give you guys so much information that you just lose yourself and a loophole
Once again, thank you and good luck